rob corddry do you want to see an
invention yes sir we're time for
inventors corner with my best friend
Kazooie rob you're gonna love them
take it away desert heat I go burger all
right okay you're my best friend I know
you are my best friend here thank you
and pleasure to meet you all
that's what you tell this is the multi
life do the holiday rod very sharp and
grateful sobbing into me and onion it
also works for hiccup but Rob has no
need for death because he doesn't have
here you go so good one really funny
Kisuke what happened
Rob do you think this is part of it or
what what another murder
yeah it's another murder ah this is
terrible it is terrible Robert and you
know what I will avenge my best friend's
death after these myths let out a garage
oh that's a kitchen and we can't eat
them
[Music]